good
pastor and second grade teacher
accused of sexual abuse with
minors is behind the
bars greeted by cristian cásseres with his
news outlet the news now in spanish the
metropolitan police indicated that
reynaldo crespín was found in
albuquerque over the weekend and  who
fled las vegas as soon as he found out
about his arrest warrant he was a
priest in the new
yor aysén christian church and also a teacher in
elementary school here for more
details visit our page ignis
naut dotcom in the spanish section i
tell you that  the metropolitan police
are searching for a
missing teenager he does not have on screen his
name is the 15-year-old diaz rivera who
was last seen on friday
fences in a brutally shiite way first he
measures 54 and weighs about 145 pounds the
authorities indicate that  he might be in
need of medical attention
and today is you ie 222 of 2022
and clark county hoping today is
the day  busier for couples
looking to take the big step the county
anticipates breaking the record for most
weddings in one day that record was
set on July 7, 2007
that is 77 of 2007 about 1800
marriage licenses were
delivered that day we are very vigilant
for  see what happens on Tuesday
and the strong winds continue throughout
the valley as we can see here on
your screen we have the forecast see in
we will have a slight chance of
rain for this afternoon that will last
until night with temperatures
barely reaching 50  degrees we
will stay in that climate on Thursday,
however the temperatures will rise for
next week I am Cristian Cásseres with
your brief information on innings in
Spanish good morning